hi for screen junkies movie fights
today's episode is brought to you by
blue apron yeah what is happening
everybody movie fights we got three
fighters for chairs we're sitting down
and it's gonna be a heck of a swell time
and you know what let's jump into the
fun and meet today's combatants for this
epic cinematic Smackdown first he is the
head writer of honest trailers he's a
former movie fights champion and he's a
very fussy eater welcome Spencer may
will prove that today interesting to be
sitting after standing I'm not sure if I
like it I kind of want to get up and
explore the space but I'll rein it in
well you always like to press your body
to its max push it to the limits by even
doing crazy things like standing for an
hour to get these chairs chairs was a
struggle um Spencer always great to have
you buddy
oh this is a friend of the family she's
back on movie fights she won her movie
fights debut the death match number two
right oh man
welcome a an esteemed nerd and fantastic
lady yell Tegel thank you I did win the
debut deathmatch number two uh-huh I can
only take credit for that that is my
title and that is what I hold on to you
know what we got oh you know I'll take
what I can get you know if you got
something hold on to it and I love that
you're bling is yeah yeah you know what
I'm gonna get my act
tattooed like a little stamp on my
back I think you should ya know change
it if you ever change it what if I
change it if Twitter goes away ya have
this weird on the back you know it's a
commitment it's like you get like you
know you get your wife's name tattooed
on your arm and then you get a divorce
so you
put a giant eagle on top I've got my
friend ster just in case it comes back
well Friendster is the only one that is
not stolen her information this
gentleman on the end you heard his voice
probably many times on the fat man on
Batman podcast he's a writer and nerd
extraordinaire please welcome Mark
Bernardin mark thank you for being here
my pleasure
my voice will haunt your dreams from now
on I'm sorry is that a threat or a
promise it all depends on how long he
stands up for okay good to know good to
know you guys I am excited for this
threesome to clash and do battle but
Before we jump into the fun let's figure
out how this is gonna go down we have
three votes going into each question my
vote and then a couple of votes coming
from the Dan camp Dan Merle and what is
up brother so what are you gonna be
doing over there I will be fact checking
to make sure that all of the arguments
are effectually correct and I'll also be
listening with my ears because I will
also have a vote and just help decide
who wins each round and also the speed
round oh heck yeah dan and I will be
judging with a firm yet fair hand and
the voice of the people the conduit who
will be relaying your votes to us she is
a national treasure
Daniel Radford so for all of you who do
not know the way that it works is is I
am the voice of you there is a poll that
is on YouTube and there are a lot of
people who put up some very sweet polls
on Twitter because they just want to be
involved and we love you but the only
official poll is the YouTube poll if you
are looking to join it that poll only
goes up after all of the fighters have
given their initial answers because we
don't want everyone to start voting for
their faith once those answers have been
given if you don't see the poll go ahead
and you can either hit that I card or go
down like either refresh or do
annotations on and off you can see it
refresh your page there is an entire way
to do
in the description below so if you have
any questions go ahead and consult that
along with making sure that if we need a
tie to be broken I will break that tie
I will also be checking all of your good
dankmemes I will be checking your tweets
I'll be ok I'll be checking all your
sick memes but primarily what we'll be
doing is if there is a tie between them
- then I become the voice of the people
if there is some way a three-way tie I
get my own voice and I hate it don't do
that to me
figure it out Daniel you know what I
noticed last week when you were fighting
you were cursing like a sailor count was
off the chart it's time for a Radford to
fight she don't fight to be the voice
the people she go chill you know we
should all live by such a code and one
of them I'm fighting for me and one of
them I'm fighting for you
mmm nice I like it well put Danielle now
we're about to throw down but before we
do that Dan has some tasty information
for me I love how you did that because
today's episode is brought to us and to
you by blue apron which if you don't
know what blue apron is it is a meal
delivery extraordinaire chef designed
meals delivered to your door in a
refrigerated box so it doesn't go bad
it's not a refrigerator though so you
have to take it out of the box in a
timely manner you know it's in here it's
enough for them to get it to you and
then you get time to put it in the
fridge they don't just send you like a
mini fridge farm-fresh ingredients you
cook it yourself I just want to make
sure that the people knows I can't wear
a box cutter refrigerator
in exactly the right portions so you
don't have food left over and they have
all in so many menus some of the items
you can choose from you can pick what
you want they send it to your door
there's no commitment so you can sign up
you get a couple meals sent to you
they're not gonna make you do it for six
months you can look at the menu every
week you can decide what meals you want
they'll send them to you cook them at
home it's delicious and starting on
April 16th they're starting a new
program they're partnering with Airbnb
for a six-week partnership they leave
this they will be providing six
specially designed meal recipes from
chefs around the world different
countries for you to try out so you got
Airbnb partnering with with blue apron
and also the first 50 people there's a
link in the description below the first
50 people to click that link will
receive $50 off their first two weeks of
blue apron go food it's healthy it's
fresh you can make it yourself you're
not gonna have a bunch of leftovers
what's not to love how oh I mean I can't
think of a blessed thing No
right Dan thank you so much for
providing that oh let me ask you a
question yessum you know what delivery
service the minions work for Oh
Groo apron then thank you all right
before we get into the actual fight like
quick breakdown of how it works
we have seven total questions that's
three regular round questions and four
speed round questions and the first
three questions the three regular round
questions are going to be decided by
myself dan and your polls the speed
round weed I will be decided by myself
Dan and Danielle's own opinions no time
for the polls in the speed round and as
I said before yet we we got it all set
you know what I think I checked all the
boxes jte dropped that sick-ass package
[Music]
[Applause]
jte the best package in the biz
all right I love them well that epic
sequence is playing it's just deathly
silent yeah like you watching a home can
here we are sitting here just like okay
it's the opposite of fight I thought
these were talkies not silent all right
question number one who is a goodie the
solo Star Wars store solo a Star Wars
story trailer dropped this week we want
to know which Star Wars character really
needs a spinoff alright which Star Wars
character needs a spin-off Spencer
you're going first
no one needs anything we don't need a
Star Wars but I'll take the question in
the spirit in which it was intended and
try to give you guys a what to me it
would be a really interesting Star Wars
spin-off movie I feel like with the
original trilogy and that's what I'm
mining from cuz that's clearly all
Disney wants to mine from I got a good
sense of Han Solo I know Luke Skywalker
by now Darth Vader's been done to death
there's an original trilogy character
that I'm really curious about he he
appears briefly and he's gone just as
fast and I have so many questions and
that is the big sweaty rank or keeper
who cries when he kills his beloved
rancor this guy his name well what is
his name it turns out it's Malachy Lee
look at that face how could you not want
to just comfort him after his horrible
beast dies what made him care so much
about this monster it's not clear I've
got questions hmm what happens after his
best friend does murder this is not a
prequel this is I imagine the first 15
minutes will be how him the monster fell
in love like the first 15 minutes of up
but we're gonna move forward from there
and really form a pearl out of this
grain of sand not Dewey just out of
curiosity are we going past the ranked
horse death yes the last scene in the
movie oh no no no we I don't like these
movies that the rogue ones where you
know how it's gonna end your face
two men I this is something that that
starts again it starts with the hate and
the rancor falling in love but then it
continues beyond you say falling in love
what kind of implant on ik respected
cast if I just want to make sure what
kind of situation we're working with
here I'll tell you more later Spencer
thank you for laying out your opening
salvo yell t go so I believe that that
what we need need is the word is a porks
spin-off and the reason that we need the
pouring spin-off is that the adult Star
Wars audience is divided if there is a
big division and it's because most
people became fans when they were
children
so to appeal to the new generation of
children we need a spin-off about the
porks and I will tell you all about my
plot outline as we get into it okay
fantastic
those adorable porks and Mark who needs
a spinoff first I just like to make it
clear that all of my answers are brought
to you by black apron mini-fridges but
no food inside hashtag sellout my answer
is a character played in rogue one by
Donnie Yen turret in way I believe his
name was the whole idea of this cat this
character being a guardian of the Wills
one of the sort of force adjacent
characters in Star Wars universe that
help protect the khyber Minds it'll
protect the the the temple of the Jedi
on the planet Jetta I think there's a
lot of story to be mine there and it's
friggin Donnie Yen like I would watch
him do anything I would watch him kill
every poured I'm just saying that's just
where I come down okay we have our three
answers mix it up let's fight alright so
it is a family film similar to the way
that minions was Oh God it obviously
would have a much better plot so it
takes like takes place after ray was on
Achtung and
pork named poplu decides that she wants
to become a Jedi she's sick of being
just food and she sets off on a journey
to Train house this subtitle
yes delicious in the end she really said
that she doesn't need to become a Jedi
just to protect her family who and she
comes back to help them actively avoid
being eaten the reason I think that this
would work and that this spin-off is
actually necessary is that there's
already a kids book of chewy and the
porks and this is what they want they
want to bring in the new generation of
Star Wars fans do they have a page in
that children's book where he eats one
of them
no I assume not if you told me it was
chewy in the pores in it was like a rock
n roll musical where they form a band
and they travel the galaxy like righting
wrongs and fighting crime at the same
time while kicking out some sick jams on
board I'm not writing a children's book
I'm writing the spin-off movie and this
is what it is that's unlike yours where
you already said doesn't we don't need a
spin-off here's an idea well I was
making a more metaphysical point but
this is the one that I need to feel
happy and to feel excited about going to
see it because I think that this
actually it's an original spin-off
because it's not about these characters
that are done to death or these
storylines that are done to death to me
the most interesting thing charit ever
did and i know someone's gonna pull out
the canon wiki or something like that
was in rogue one that was the peak of
his life otherwise he's like he said
he's guarding crystals lissa crystal
guard monka molecules peak was what we
saw that was his life we don't know I'll
tell you clearly
he joins up with a group of Star Wars a
eco-terrorist it's like oak tree like
he's liberating her these Forgotten
creatures across the Star Wars universe
all the tossed aside like a fantastic
beast type picture where where it's
exploring a aspect of stars that we
don't see too much which is the
creatures the aliens the beauty and we
don't ever see aliens or creatures like
this they're kind of cat in background
you know they're just like passing
through a special addition to like block
just like fantastic beasts we don't need
it
Wow what we do need is to remind
everyone that you loved these movies as
a child and that what we need is the new
children to also love it that's not
gonna remind me of the movies I loved as
a child that's gonna be like Oh Star
Wars is for babies now I'm a man Star
Wars was for you when you were a child
I'm not saying it's not for us now let
me be clear but I am saying that the
reason that our fans are so divided now
is because our childhoods are ruined
with the new stuff what we need is to
remember that this was made for children
and here is a new version to bring new
children into the Star Wars that's gonna
be divisive I mean everything Star Wars
is gonna be divisive now but I don't
think making a clearly kiddy focused
Star Wars movie is gonna heal the bonds
it'll just be ignored by anyone over six
mark I haven't heard a lot from you I
would love to hear more about what you
envisioned for your film well I mean my
my vision for what a movie would be
about it's the Seven Samurai it's about
you know a band of these mall cops who
are and find themselves on this planet
having to defend the the khyber minds
having to defend the jedi temple from
the JT temple the Jedi Temple from but I
think it's it's it's a tragedy it's a
it's a last stand it's an Alamo movie
and it's you get to see how this dude
who clearly can still kick a bunch of
ass can I say as if she can curse up a
storm I would like to see how that dude
loses his sight I would like to see the
last end of the of the guardians of the
wheels I would like to see how this
helps build the story going forward how
I mean the original Star Wars trilogy
was called the Journal of the Wills
let's see what that means something
let's dig into the death in a Last Stand
movie it was rogue one we already saw
that yes you're just repeating rogue one
again and he also who was another mall
cops movie speak for yourself
to me the the issue with with charity
was a really cool character and like I
want to know more about him but I also
don't trust that instinct anymore
because I wanted to know more about Boba
Fett and I found out and I don't like it
and I wanted to know more about Darth
Vader and I found out and I don't like
it like I don't trust Star Wars anymore
to make cool characters more cool well
I don't trust George Lucas to tell me
how this you want to take a boring
character that was amusing for a minute
and try to stretch I want to take
something unformed that he could be our
our conduit into new and exciting Star
Wars Star Wars our unformed we don't
know anything about them we don't know
how they got on to this island and if
they can be my Gration their verse don't
know if they actually understand English
or not and you're you're positing that
the the poor the central pork of your
story poplu is gonna become a Jedi
try she's gonna try and fail it's going
to try she wants to explore the Janet
she's seen ray their training she's like
I want to do it so she goes off to Train
realizes she doesn't need to be a Jedi
to protect her family from being eaten
do they give her like a cocktail
lightsaber like this a little tiny one
for the mother she doesn't need it what
part of me but she tries and fails she
doesn't fail she finds out then it was
always there all along Thank You Dumbo
but you say porks aren't divisive and
sadly I don't even want to give this
troll the credit but I will never forget
somebody who commented of saying that
chewy eating the pork was SJW propaganda
for veganism so even poets have their
divisive nature even people and tons of
people like they turn Star Wars for kids
people hate that about start again who
is your audience right who is your
audience this one is clearly just made
for this audience to go listen you're
gonna grow up and you're gonna love Star
Wars and we're gonna bring you into this
world I mean every Star Wars movies for
kids though right like kids who love
incest
happy national sibling day everybody but
it's these were always children's movies
that's what they were designed to be not
that I'm all about the pores but the
idea that you can't give children a
little bit of tragedy along with their
cute and fluffy they operate at multiple
levels and I think that this animal
movie is this a Star Wars creature
wrangling movie can operate it like oh
wow look at that animal and there can be
porks in mine he can wrangle up some
pores and save them from an evil he was
eat them okay let's shift gears here and
here's some final thoughts from
everybody Spencer like I said this is
something that we haven't seen before
it's a character that one you once you
point him out there are questions that
are raised and it's not something that
we're sick of I think you could use him
as your propulsion through a new world
of Star Wars that gets you to think
about the creatures that everyone looks
at is lesser and cast aside in some
weird slug man's basement and no like
actually they are important we should go
out and try and cherish them and free
them from their bonds all right thank
you for that
synopsis yealt eagle I think of these
this is the the ports film about poplu
pork is the only one that has a vision a
reason a need and also an audience I
think Papua is going to be the new ray
[Music]
there you have it pop Laporte and Peppa
Pig mark go ahead and give us your
closing thoughts I think that the
cherdon way could be the center of a
movie that that calls to mind the way we
felt about Empire Strikes Back which was
it is a serious movie it is a tragedy
it's a movie that introduces people to
tragedy for the first time but being
able to tell the the fall of a hallowed
temple and star wars law to be able to
bring a bunch of martial arts into it
and to be able to give done again a way
to shine in these movies I don't know
man if you tell me that I'm gonna get a
seven samurai in space I will take a
seven samurai in space time Wow
okay man three really interesting movies
that probably will never get made chance
let's go to Dan on the factual ''tis
before we get into the judging well one
thing
to confirm Spencer's indeed correct
because I told him about this comment I
indeed found it we did get a comment
saying that the pork scene was Star Wars
further pushing its liberal agenda by
endorsing veganism / vegetarianism
that's what I took away from that and
went on to say a lot of other things
that person doesn't get to comment
anymore
embracing the corny agenda right corgis
you could say it was a scene of high
comedy in a Star Wars movie but let's go
with Mirchi Sigma Spencer I'm sure that
some people will are already on your
Twitter but the the Canon established
story with Malik le believe it or not is
that he eventually ended up opening a
restaurant in moss eisely was javis
former chef you are free of course as
Star Wars itself is going to rewrite
history and do what you want look
forward to Jedi Master chef as far as
factual analysis that's about all that I
have so you know this is all conjecture
these were pitches so not a lot of facts
to follow up on the Wills of course
something that George Lucas established
very early on his original version of
what would eventually become the force
but are now being interwoven into the
actual Star Wars filmic mythology gotcha
alright so we had three different movies
this was a fairly applied opening around
not a lot of rancor this so Man three
very different films Spencer I really
loved your idea but I feel like you
didn't give us enough of a picture of
what your film would be you left it kind
of this amorphous thing of just like
okay this guy and his creature you know
I wanted just a little taste of what
that journey would be like and you know
what this guy like did he find this
little rank or hatchling and he raised
and then bought it or yeah yeah yeah
what you said okay
so it came down to yell and mark for me
and I agree with some of the things that
took you down yell as for some of the
takedowns as far as the porks are
divisive and then Spencer asked you if
it would be a subtitled film so and you
said yes so it's gonna be subtitled and
a family film I don't know if that makes
also I'm it seemed vastly different and
they pointed this out from the
complicated tone of a Star Wars film
that it appeals to adults and kids so
but mark still had to prove his case and
when he painted the notion of a seven
samurai in space and the this team of
samurais led by Don Ian's blinds
essentially samurai in from rogue one
defending the khyber minds that just got
me excited that was the thing where am i
okay
that's what I need to see and no one
really had a huge takedown of him you
you mentioned that they've messed up
some backstories before but that's the
you know it's the old regime and Donnie
Yen was so cool and rogue on that's the
one for me mark you get my point let's
go to Dan
oh wow this this was also between Yale
and mark for me and III agree that the
Spencer's was a clever idea but I just
didn't get a good idea of what the movie
was gonna be other than that he's the
rancor guy and that would be kind of
funny yeah it's really more I think
yellow painted a much better picture of
the actual movie for me than mark did
but mark had a stronger argument on the
tone of what he was going for so this is
actually very close but I mean based
it's not the movie that I would go see
but based on the arguments I think Yale
actually had the strongest take on what
her movie would be I thought she
best argument for the tone and the plot
and everything so Alex I'm gonna go with
yell because I think that she had the
best thought out idea okay
it's it's one for the blind samurai one
for the poor go Palooza let's go to the
YouTube poll like it is very
overwhelming for the blind 65% Malachy
Lee is at 24% and I agree with you again
they look like corgis with wings
they got 9% so that that's what we got I
will say that a couple of things there
weren't any I haven't seen you take
memes yet I still appreciate y'all but a
lot if people were wondering why we were
not talking about the fact that there
should be a couple of prequels
especially in Lando movie especially now
that we have a dog lover hopefully
that's what lol yeah yes back to Orlando
I mean so maybe doing the heavy lifting
for the the Lando movie there any any
other dank suggestions for some dank
suggestions um yeah no it's just mostly
Orlando Lando will you even gotta love
Lando um they want the winner like
there's not really a right yeah there
you have it
so your dank things if you have like a
weird theory or something you haven't
heard or something you think won't work
I might say it senator dang that's gonna
be the name of my new skate clothes
company dank theory okay um you take it
with the blind samurai by the way if you
enjoyed flying samurais
out the old samurai code of SATA Ichi
the blind samurai yeah deep cut from the
50s and 60s mark you are ahead one to
nil and let's see the second question
here it is what is ooh what is the best
horror movie of the past ten years what
is the best horror movie of the past ten
years question number two we'll start
with player number two yell the best
horror movie the last ten years was
Black Swan great opening argument just
boom name-drop yeah drop I made more
sorry alright yeah thank you
mark what is the best horror movie the
past ten years
III will go with what I'm pretty sure is
the only horror movie the last ten years
to win an Oscar get out get out all
right horn - Spencer I picked you no
a big tent it can contain a lot
of things and I think you know there's
some good things about Black Swan I
think these are all fine films so I
picked the movie that made me the most
uneasy that made me the most scared and
that was where he's torturing elephants
no that was it follows okay so we have
Black Swan get out and it follows folks
fight it out great let me first of all
correct you that get out wall did win
Best Original Screenplay Black Swan won
Best Actress for Natalie petty was also
nominated for Best Director and Best
Picture
take that job away from Dan
so it follows it follows felt a lot like
an allegory against premarital sex
that's really what it was everybody was
just you'd do it and then you die or you
have to keep doing it and pass it on
it's kind of like they're saying hey
children don't do this and that's not a
horror film that's not scary that's
propaganda but Black Swan was
a metaphor for achieving artistic
perfection with all the psychological
and physical challenges you will
encounter the price you pay to get to
that level and it's a psychological
thriller with a female lead where she's
not being chased by a ghost or she's
being chased by men or you know she's
being chased by her own ambition and
herself and the notion of being haunted
by a double and that is terrifying okay
so it follows there's many different
readings of it you could look at it as a
metaphor for sexually transmitted
disease obviously Black Swan if you
would throw that you're playing the sex
card again from Black Swan Black Swan is
about the virgin ballerina who's like
too perfect and never touches herself
against like the the sex pot like the
Mila Kunis is like the sexy one who
seduces the boss and stuff like that
this is like the most stereotypical like
good girl Madonna you know what complex
movie ever I think you're missing it
it's about a woman who is trying to come
into her own and puts all of this
pressure on herself to be both aspects
of this it is a message about how
society tells women they have to be one
or the other and it's an interesting way
that we as women internalize that and
put so much pressure that she goes
actually crazy
but the the pressure she puts ourself it
to me and I guess this is the thing
here's the bigger picture about Black
Swan is they who knows what it's about
this is a movie that I was watching I
was like what's happening what's real
what isn't and that's interesting that's
something this is obviously great food
for discussion but it wasn't something
that I walked away from being like wow
what a satisfying film I knew exactly
what was happening yeah I mean I think
horror is a genre that begs for clarity
in a way like you have to know what it
is in order to be afraid of it and
Darren Aronofsky has never really
trucked in clarity that's just not the
thing that he does but I disagree that
you have to know what it is to be afraid
but I think what's scarier is not
knowing what's at if it's real or not
and the hallucinations that she has
that's terrifying she doesn't know if
she actually killed someone I think that
works the first few times they did it
but that was my takeaway from that
movies they kept doing the head fake if
it's real it's fake it's real it's fake
it's real it's fake and that wore off
after a while where it follows like you
said clarity you know in the first nine
minutes something is going to wash
something's going
to get you and then that's the
behind you that's the scariest thing to
stop having sex there's someone walking
is yes that anxiety of like this better
slow oncoming inescapability of death I
must finish fast enough so that it does
not catch me that's yeah that's what
that movie was about was this my schools
about sex in high school lucky lucky I
mean I think and then it followed I mean
[Laughter]
super fun yeah the idea that that Jordan
Peele has honed through you know years
of making key and peele years of making
short genre pieces it was figured out
and cracked not entirely a new formula
of what he's calling social horror but
the idea that that get out is about
fundamentally the devaluation of black
bodies it is about and coming to us in a
world that is currently wrestling with
black lives matter and wrestling with me
too and wrestling with who gets to tell
what story and who gets to be the hero
of what story to get a story that feels
like this that gets to the core of what
the black experience in white America is
like and using that as a metaphor for
body horror using it as a metaphor for
displacement using it as a metaphor for
a disassociation using it as a metaphor
for subjugation like it does all of
these things while being still a
crackerjack movie that still makes a
turn in the in the third act to straight
out and out horror and I feel that that
there are a few movies that get to do
this thing in this way and I actually do
feel like it follows is more that thing
to me than Black Swan was in that we're
talking about a very real issue a very
real scenario but using horrors that
metaphor to get to the deeper quick of
what it is I think that that all of
these these topics that definitely need
to be addressed in and were addressed
beautifully were why you won Best
Original Screenplay where as a
performance by Natalie Portman in this
amazing turn where she had to play this
you know part of of the the Madonna the
White Swan and the Black Swan and and
the fighting internally and externally
in the hallucinations is why she won the
award for Best Actress I mean Sean
Connery's really great in Zardoz
like it does not make a great movie to
have a great performance in it yes the
the performance um and just on a
technical level that movie is like the
camera in Natalie Portman's face for
like 90% of it and that's cool but also
like disorienting I think from a
stylists perspective
it follows was one of the most stylish
movies of the last 10 years it had a
look that was like it was familiar it
was just off enough to be unsettling and
this matching it with a score that
perfectly complemented what was going on
that it was like this homage to 80s
horror but also it was like kind of
existed out of time like this was
something that could have come out in an
alternate dimension I just it stuck with
me more than anything else it fellows
felt to me like it could have been any
of the horror movies that came out that
year or in the last 10 years it just
felt very like this is a horror movie
teens are doing things something is
chasing them it's going to kill them it
reminds me of truth or dare that's
coming out now it feels very similar
Black Swan was so creative and original
and the terrible I'm saying that the
fears is not knowing what's real like
could you imagine life not knowing
what's real every day man for me the
thing that that get out does better than
either these movies is it seduces you
into the reality of the movie it brings
you into the what it's like to be that
kid what it's like to live in a world in
which every five minutes something weird
happens and you're not sure if it's real
or not you're not sure if you notice it
or not you're not microaggressions also
being the sort of attack vector for
horror is kind of phenomenal and and the
idea that an audience that had never had
that life experience can understand what
that feels like is is for me it's it's a
it's a huge accolade it's a huge it's
huge summit to reach the top of is to
get a wide audience understand what it's
like to be black in America and the
horror of that and that's and it was a
great movie but like you said the horror
doesn't it doesn't become an out-and-out
horror movie until the third act
otherwise it's a suspense it's a
thriller it's a mystery you're like even
he isn't sure what's going on even after
he's been hypnotized like they keep
ramping the tension down and then back
up and then only in the end though they
like alright it's a horror movie you got
a
in the house it falls to counter the
boring argument yes they are just
walking towards you
they don't stop yes they can take the
form of someone you love someone you
know imagine how scary it is to have
your dead naked dad slowly walking after
you and if it touches you he's gonna you
know what you did death
it's terrifying and you can't get rid of
it the horrifying thing about is you
have to make the choice between am I
going to run for the rest of my life or
am I going to kill somebody else that's
horrible
I think that what is scarier is knowing
that you have this goal in life that you
want to do something with your life and
that the only thing to do is push
yourself further and further into a
place where you not only have abusive
people in your life but you are also
self harming and getting yourself to a
point where you may have actually killed
someone just to achieve your goal and in
the end you end up hurting yourself only
okay let's go around here some final
thoughts oops yeah I'll go ahead and
continue what is your final points you
want to make remarks one I think that
one of the things that makes Black Swan
the best horror film of the past 10
years is that it is original it is
creative it is clever it is different it
gives you this perspective that you may
not have had if you're not necessarily
an athlete or a dancer or someone who
has to train so hard and live in this
life and and get to a point where you've
actually broken your own mind and that
is terrifying the idea that you know
their doubles and doppelgangers that
might be coming after you and it's
really just yourself that is terrifying
and I think that the good old fashioned
horror film of you know of teens getting
murdered great we've done it this is new
this is clever
thanks yell mark I mean I feel to me
horror is about this objective it's
about the the how it makes you feel and
how it pushes your personality purses
your your psyche to the edge of reality
the edge of sanity I think that get-out
makes that subjective argument
incredibly passionately and it makes it
incredibly literally and the idea that
that a horror movie needs to always be
horror feels like it's countermanded by
psycho which is not at all horror until
you get to win its horror like that
doesn't feel like it's a requirement for
for being scary
it just it's part of the seduction it's
part of the spell the I thought this
movie was one thing it's something
totally different and if I watch it
again it all tracks all the way
throughout I think that there's there's
a masterwork missed to get out in that
that I don't think I leave the other
movies match thank you Mark Spencer to
me it follows it was visually and
sonically a cut above for horror movies
for the last ten years and to me just
like you said subjectively the scariest
part of the horror movie for me is when
you know the monsters coming you don't
know when it's gonna get you but you
know it's got its sights on you and it's
advancing and they made the entire movie
out of the scariest part of the horror
movie for me you can't get away there's
nothing you can do to get away from this
thing and yeah and it's just the death
by like a thousand cuts of like this
slow-moving thing it's not gonna be a
jump scare it's just gonna be monotonous
and it's coming and it's right over your
shoulder no matter how far you run that
to me just it really got me on a
visceral level whereas get out and and
Black Swan got me unlike a an
intellectual and emotional level but it
wasn't like the way that it follows was
okay wow what a scary round that was
thank you for your arguments folks let's
go to Dan Morrell on the fact-check no
Corrections just kind of an answer to a
rhetorical question that Mark asked
about other horror movies in the last
decade or so that have been winning
Oscars other than Black Swan which a
yell mentioned the wolf man won an Oscar
actually the same year the Black Swan
won for a Best Makeup other than that
and get out the horror genre pretty
unrepresented as far as Oscar winners in
the last decade gotcha
Benicio Del Toro's Wolfman Wolfman yeah
most iconic horror character of all time
Benicio del Toro's Wolfman Dan why don't
you keep talking and fill us in on your
take this round three great pitches I
mean everybody sold their movie really
well so for me it's it's it's really
just kind of parsing the arguments and
just making a very subjective call for
me I guess the
the kind of feather that tips the scale
is I felt that I felt that Spencer sold
the specificity as far as the horror
element the monster the the the the the
consistent terror throughout the best
for me so in a very very close round
just for the specificity of the horror
element throughout I'm gonna side with
Spencer but it's a very difficult
decision yeah this that's one point for
Spencer it was quite a difficult
decision breaking this down and picking
a winner here because you have such
different films and I feel like yell
mark and Spencer really painted a
picture of how their film fits into the
horror genre and how it excels and at
the end of the day I think Mark had the
most bullet points just as far as his
neck film nailing a very specific
metaphor fitting it to the horror genre
and transcending the genre and lifting
it to be the best horror film of the
past 10 years and since no one argued
for the Snowman I have to go with Mark
with get out even though there were
great arguments across the board we're
locked up again tied at 1-1 danielle
help us out here alright well let's go
to the people and the people have pretty
definitively spoken once again we've get
out at 54% it follows at 34% in wax one
11 percent I will say one really kind of
fun thing that we saw on the Twitter was
at Jack and a squirt D underscore
Manheim said it follows us great but it
really raises a lot of uncomfortable
technical questions do condoms qualified
is qualify the curse
specified people need to climax yo I
used to be a part of Planned
Parenthood's team council and I used to
get the best questions about how
reproduction worked any other
suggestions as far as some of the past
ten years enough how much love babadook
got yeah what a tough question but get
out takes it today and Mark you Walt
ahead to zero zero let's go to question
number three movie fights who should
replace Joss Whedon as batgirls director
who should replace Joss Whedon as
batgirls director and we're gonna start
with Mark in thinking about this idea I
started to reckon my brain about what I
want from a bad girl director who what
what capacity what talents what
sensibilities where I want somebody to
bring but you're gonna movie and I was
looking for grit I was looking for
muscle I was looking for an experience
and superhero comic book filmmaking I
was looking for somebody who knows what
a good fight feels like and somebody who
also can can blend both the feminine and
the powerful not that those things were
ever really separate but on-screen that
takes him doing so as to not over
masculinize a heroine the way the state
James Cameron does but to find the path
between finding yourself and finding
your place and finding your voice and
finding your power and so I went with
Lexi Alexander who directed Punisher war
zone who's done some great work on shows
like arrow and Supergirl and is an Oscar
winner herself for for a short film she
made
back in the early 2000s I think but yeah
she's she's got 19 black belts she
actually knows how to make a camera do
what she wants it to do and and she I
think gets the the street-level violence
need from-from Burnside or Gotham or
wherever they decide to set this with
also a lot of cinematic flair so yeah
Lexie is my pick all right Lexi
Alexander background a Spencer
I picked a TV director you may have
heard of had some forays into film
upcoming and in the past Michelle
Maclaren and she's someone who can take
genre material like many other skilled
directors but elevate it this is a woman
who's directed the best episodes of
Breaking Bad Ozymandias of Game of
Thrones of West world of Walking Dead of
the x-files if you go back long enough
she's someone who's proven that she can
take this material and mind you these
directors aren't writing the movie the
movie has a writer and they can execute
it with the seriousness and get great
performances out of their actors and
just make it beautiful and she's done
that time and time again with all of the
prestige TV in the world I'd like to see
what she can do with the movie Thank You
Spencer and thank you for telling us how
movies work the director doesn't have to
write it Jenkins who proved herself with
a Wonder Woman also according to an
article of variety she replaced Michelle
cheated on Wonder Woman because she was
unaccustomed to the laborious
development process of assosiated with
making movies conflicting reports
according to this variety article and
also yeah I chose patty Jenkins I'll get
to it when we fight alright mix it up
y'all okay so did one episode of arrow
one episode of Supergirl what I was over
limitless what I was sort of taken what
episode I had to get it with murder what
episode why only one episode well she is
a sort of journeyman television director
more of him than not they just bounce
from show to show to show to show to
show occasionally you get a game of
Thrones that begins
incorporate directors because it's such
a giant hard thing to reckon with if you
can they keep you in house but TV
directing is is your you're a freelance
gunslinger and that's the way that works
she's also working in the feature space
she's also developing her own TV shows
she's also a black belt punching people
in the face a lot does black belt help
you direct films yeah it can help with
action if we're getting but I would just
want to say that if we're getting
another Punisher war zone like that
movies dated already late if you watch
it in its 2008 it's been Jesus it's been
10 years what you want is someone who
has experience working in the DC she's
got to do much too close she's doing
Wonder Woman to and you don't want to
Zack Snyder her and just put make
everything just kind of homogeneous in
this universe oh you don't like that you
would think that she would ever turn
into Zacks I mean in the sense that
you're handing him one director every
project in your universe it's all gonna
have the same do you see when someone's
great I mean they're different they're
different characters different
properties different locations she yes
my director Michelle Maclaren got
removed from Wonder Woman but this ain't
one released by yeah but this ain't
Wonder Woman this is Batgirl she's shown
that she can make street-level shows
like from criminals with Breaking Bad
and she can do as she did the deuce
which is like the first few episodes of
that which is like a great grimy 70s New
York show their hour-long it's not that
big of a leap to imagine that she could
do another like tough down in the gutter
but like with great character beats and
great great everything I love penny
Jenkins to death I think she did a
fantastic job with Wonder Woman I have
no doubt she'll do a fantastic job with
Wonder Woman - but those movies take up
four to five years of your life of which
that is the only thing you can do is
make that one movie you cannot do that
and do Batgirl at the same time and I'd
like to have a Batgirl movie in the next
ten years and I just feel like that
would be overtaxing that person as great
as she is why would you saddle one
person with both of those movies when
you can have another person deliver
those movies
moans apart so your argument is that she
is too busy not that she isn't the best
person for the job
she literally can't without delaying a
movie fruit bite so many years I just
don't want these two to look and feel
the same there are different characters
in different universes like completely
different scales of action you're
working on I think you could get
somebody action of Breaking Bad is
definitely going to be equal to the
action of a team of Batgirl yeah it's
it's a criminal it's a criminal show
she's fighting crime it's a show it's a
movie we're trying to make a movie here
making them moving in movie pictures is
that a Batgirl story does not need to be
a one hundred million dollar affair it
does not need to be a 200 million dollar
affair it is a girl in a suit is
fighting crime in a city that might as
well be a ten million dollar indie that
might as well be a 20 million dollar
sort of mid-range film I think that
Lexie Allen's owner can absolutely
wrestle that to the ground not to say
the Michelle Maclaren coding or not to
say the patty Jenkins were she not
married and I have to cheat on her
spouse gal gadot with another lady
couldn't do that but I think that there
was something unique about Lexie there's
something unique about both her
upbringing as a bit of an outsider as a
martial artist and given that this movie
has to be all about martial arts like
David leach is a martial artist he did
amazing work on John wick and Deadpool
too because he knows how that works he
knows what the human body can do Lexi
knows what the human body can do she
knows what a woman's body can do in a
way that other these directors sometimes
don't but you're talking action action
action and to me I've never seen the
Lexi Alexander project that listed like
the amazing performance that Michelle
MacLaren's gotten out of let's bryan
cranston or out of emilia clark and in
the projects that she's directed she
clearly has a way to speak with actors
and to get great performances out of her
or his punishment war zone it was it's
camp it was good but it was camp asking
for someone to get a performance out of
amazing actors who already have amazing
you know
credits to their name that everyone's
seen whereas gal gadot was not a name
that we knew i mean i'm live in israel
for people still can
name correctly so apparently they don't
know her I think that patty Jenkins is
the right one for this she knows how to
work within the Warner world and give
them what they want she knows how to
work with the DC Universe and make it
what we need it to be but this is one of
my biggest criticisms of the Marvel
Universe's until recently and even then
to some extent like they all have this
kind of Sami feel when it comes to the
tone like the literal look of the film
they all kind of look the same and I
don't think you need that what that was
exciting about DC is like we're gonna be
out tour driven we're gonna give control
to these directors but they just kept
giving it to Zack Snyder it's just like
let someone else play in the sandbox
okay let's have a quick final thoughts
mark we're gonna start with you yeah I
mean I think that that for me I want I
want both the sensitivity that that Lexi
can bring to to a film like this she's
she's done really great work with
Melissa Benoist done on Supergirl she
absolutely understands what that feels
like to be a young feminine person
fighting their way through the world and
making their name as I go forward she
absolutely knows what action feels like
she absolutely knows what it's like to
punch somebody in the face and can help
guide an actor through what that feels
like and again she's got an Oscar under
her belt
and I think that the fact that she has
been a journeyman director in TV that
she had one movie ten years ago she's
hungry she's hungry in a way that
Michelle Maclaren is and she's oh I'm
gonna weigh that patty Jenkins
absolutely isn't and hunger counts for a
lot
thank you Mark around the horn dispenser
Michelle Maclaren she's savvy she's in
the thick of it she's working in the
best television shows that we have right
now which is in my opinion the best
storytelling we have right now
she's elevated material time and time
again and she's not going to bring us a
meanness to the DCU that's that's
plagued Marvel to this point thank you
and yell we're finally giving women a
chance to lead in front of and behind
the camera and I think that we have seen
patty Jenkins prove herself that she can
handle this and no one knows yet if it
would be the same that we keep seeing no
one knows if she is a Zack Snyder who
can only do one thing we don't know that
because we have to give her the shot and
we've she's proven that she can do
something great let's give her a shot to
do it again awesome thank you yell and
thank you fighters
or talking about three potentially
strong candidates there uh for Batgirl
let's go to down on the facts
just a couple facts like Xena was
nominated for an Academy on for about
Academy Award for Best live action short
but lost the sort was called Johnny
Flynn too but she wasn't Academy /
nominee which is way more than I can say
and their her an Emmy nominee Dan there
were a lot of reports about Michelle
Maclaren leaving Wonder Woman some of
them cited studio concerns about the
scale of the project in addition to a
lot of reports saying that they also had
a different vision Michelle Maclaren
wanted a kind of broader epics feel one
Warner Brothers wanted a more character
focused feel which is kind of what
generally what they got when they were
at patty Jenkins on board so there were
reportedly some concerns about the scale
also about a creative difference in
vision factually that's about it great
thank you sir Wow so you both you all
three of you painted strong arguments
for why your director has a particular
set of skills that would suit them for
this job of Batgirl and yet mark you had
a really interesting point I love your
John wick analogy with the director
bringing so much action to that film and
we love the action of John wick and that
factors in so much to that - yeah when
you called him out as like why was Lexi
Alexander only directing one episode of
each I thought you were going to give us
an answer like it's because she stole
from every sense and you posited patty
Jenkins who did I think we can all agree
that very successful - amazing job I
mean it's very positive job on Wonder
Woman and some people think she knocked
down a park something like yeah but I
didn't I feel like I didn't hear enough
of this
specifics about her style if I get some
good takedowns of the other fellas but
as far as what made patty Jenkins above
and beyond
so for me it came down to Spencer and
Mark on this one and Spencer I thought
you're listing of Michele McLaren's IMDB
and some of the best episodes and just
that reinforcement of if she can do it
and I agree with you where so much of
the best storytelling is happening on TV
at the end of the day that took it home
for me and oh and a neck-and-neck close
race I got to give it to Spencer let's
go to damn I went a different direction
I think that for majority of the fight
both Spencer and Yale were playing
defense and having to kind of fight off
reasons why their picks could not do it
and I think that Mark was playing
offense in a way that neither one of
neither Spence Andrea really fought back
on about what specifically likes
Alexander to bring to the project what
her experience doing movies would inform
and and how that would make it better
and I felt like instead of defending his
pick Marc really was able to fight for
it a lot more and I don't feel like the
takedowns from either one of them were
were overwhelmed that so I'm actually
gonna go for Marc all right we are tied
up again and we're going to Danielle to
decide all right I am the people the the
votes are still coming in fast and
furious
so as of right now our overwhelming
winner is Michelle Maclaren
Michael Aaron that's fine with Lexi
Alexander pulling in a three strong 29%
and patty Jenkins at a 10 percent
they are people that don't want patty
Jenkins drag back girl I will say is
also some of the things I have seen both
in chat and on the Twitter please I love
that some of you want me to do it but
clearly I'm busy I have to take care of
my wig Kathryn Bigelow got a lot of Big
Ups Marti Noxon got a lot of Big Ups and
that's one that I'm like heck yeah if
you don't know who Marti Noxon is very
big on Buffy she was also one of them
she's been a huge show writer on a lot
of her favorite shows if you do not know
who she is
check her out I think she would do a
great job Gail Simone a lot of people
who were huge comic book fans have said
that Gail Simone can do it because she
knows how to speak the visual language
which is probably true and now I think
we enter the time when I have to have my
own opinions yes sorry okay so it is
time to jump into the speed round and we
have a close match here mark with two
Spencer is one yeah thank you for being
delightful and bringing up some
excellent pointing yes I'm so honored to
be here absolutely we're honored to have
you all right at speed round time so
before we get to the speed round we've
got some very exciting news about our
women in film charity event dan don't
you fill us in on that that's right if
you don't know we are doing a fundraiser
for women in film our goal was $10,000
when we launched two days ago we're at
eighteen thousand eight hundred dollars
somebody pay this ten thousand dollars
just to do a doctor on this trailer
which we don't know how to do but we're
gonna figure
a couple days it'll be fine an honest
trailer 50 years on the make we we
announced today the 20k stretch goal
which was that we are going to finally
do the honest trailer of honest trailers
but it's going to be written by the
predictive AI robot that wrote that fake
Harry Potter chapter that came out a
while ago that's if we get to Twitter
Jonas and you know what it's looking
like we're at 18 thousand eight hundred
forty dollars I think we're gonna get
over that you know let's get to 18 nine
before the end of the show let's get to
80 with this with $60 away but we're so
close to 20,000 and unlocking that we
wanted to sweeten the pot a little bit
don't you want a robot to write on his
trailer specifically dr. Robotnik yes
specifically I'm still trying to
convince them to add sonic rings to the
trailer but I don't they will I think
but we wanted to sweeten the pot a
little bit so we're gonna announce our
next stretch goal right now we're almost
at 20k at twenty two thousand five
hundred dollars there is somebody that
many people have wanted to see involved
and would like to see back here on
screen junkies Alicia Malone herself
will return to judge a fight during our
movie fights extravaganza if we get to
twenty two thousand five hundred it will
be the return of Alicia Malone here two
movie fights to be judging a very
special round as only she can she
probably knows more about movies than
all of us combined that's why that's why
she's on all the movie things she'll be
making a movie fights return for our
extravaganza to judge a very special
fight so 22,500 you're gonna get the
return of Alicia Malone and at 20,000
which I think are gonna be out pretty
soon you get the AI honest trailer and
we're if you guys keep generously
donating to this cause and our
fundraiser we're gonna keep coming up
with cool stuff and stretch goals so
thank you thank you for how awesome is
this yeah
how much how much do they need to donate
to get the tote bag tell me that is a 25
grand since alicia is my friend and i
never to see her anymore because that
was like a my friend it would be great
okay I can't explain it
yeah can't just text her or something no
have you seen it yes your oh she's all
over the place
dan thank you for the 401 one alright
let's get into the speed round so we
have four speed round questions again
how this works they the first person to
answer gets to elaborate and give their
argument first and we go to the to the
other to their opponent and then
rebuttal rounds 20 seconds 20 seconds 10
seconds 10 seconds and again that it
will be judged by myself Dan and
Danielle will be giving her own opinions
now give me your own opinions but we
enjoy your opinions all right mark you
feeling it yeah Spencer whoa yes there
you go I'm also feeling it yeah thank
you but it doesn't really matter right
now but I'm glad to hear that awesome ah
first question of the speed round the
first trailer for the film the Meg was
released this week it got too many
questions what should play the giant
shark via motion capture Terry Crews we
have Terry Crews and Doug Jones
mark mark smoke first 20 seconds begin
whenever you speak because that dude is
like a human shark he's giant he's live
he's his pecs bounce I would watch that
dude do almost anything including play a
giant shark
I got sounds about I didn't know there
was a bell because look at the man just
look at all right time Spencer Doug
Jones has fish experience
he's got fish mocap experience he took a
fish monster I know it's got a heart too
but he took that too Oscar gold - the
best picture he can clearly inhabit an
aquatic creature and give it menace and
give it grace and give it subtlety he's
the only person qualified for this role
in all of Hollywood ten second rebuttal
mark Terry got no time for you Doug
Jones man Terry I just do shark
seriously it's like LL Cool J sounds
like a shark fin don't don't mess with
Terry Crews we would get another theme
song and the greatest level of deep blue
sea or his hat was indeed like shark fin
Terry Crews you're robbing Terry Crews
of his agency if it's of his himself
all right wow what a Smackdown Danielle
oh man these are both fantastic
arguments but I will say I I love both
Doug Jones's work as Mac tonight and
Terry Crews his work as Terry Crews do
believe he could be a very compelling
human shark but I will say I was swayed
by both Spencer's argument about the
Oscar and how he is not LL and I was
also swayed by arguments about how
you're robbing Terry Crews of his agency
I'm very so i dented it blah blah blah
they're all very good arguments I'm
going with Doug Jones okay that's one
for special games I love a good deep
blue sea original motion picture
soundtrack anytime but Spencer had this
round for me I'm gonna have to go with
Doug Jones okay
my vote doesn't mean a damn thing
Spencer you take that point and we are
locked up two to one the world okay
this is a barn burner now folks question
two of the speed round david leitch is
directing the jason statham
slash the rock fast and furious spinoff
what actors should play the villain the
shark from Meg mark Mill Street I mean
two of our greatest actors as shark
extreme we heard the sharp from Meg
first Spencer 20 seconds again where we
speak
what an amazing twist to the end of the
Meg if this is a backdoor preview to the
Hobbs and Jason Statham movie Oh played
by the affirmation Doug Jones this is
going to be one of the most threatening
ones of our time and there's no human
that can compete with the rock and Jason
Statham in an ass-kicking contest you
got to go big not just a shark no a
Megalodon the Meg is back and it's gonna
be looking for revenge time time all
right
listen we've had Charlize Theron we've
had Helen Mirren it is high time for
America's greatest actress to may be
punch the rock in the face I'm just
saying I would watch that in a heartbeat
I would pay good money I'll pay your
money to watch that happen I think that
an actress like meg Ryan not meg Ryan
Meryl Streep elevates this to it to a
level of let's say Clash of the Titans
which had more Oscar words than anybody
had any right to clearly you got Meg on
the brain you can't get the man getting
ahead because it works if you'd said no
Streep as a battle of wits again against
them maybe but you said punch no I don't
believe them in a physical one-on-one
fight I want to see both the rock and
Jason Statham doing double Superman
punches against time rebuttal I cannot
rebut Meryl Streep against a CG shark
come on it's my friggin Street goddamn
it have you seen her
she's the Iron Lady
okay one one clarification would you be
playing Margaret Thatcher alright let's
start with Dan oh boy I mean the
Margaret Thatcher thing almost swings we
back over to the other side I I think
the point that won me over was no human
can can face the combined force of the
rocket Jason Statham's so you kind of
have to have a shark I have to go with
Spencer and the Meg okay that's one for
Spencer with the Meg Danielle um I have
to disagree because I agree with the
idea of making this making it a backdoor
prequel Meryl Streep if there is any
human and I do feel like the point was
made especially when he called her The
Iron Lady who better to go up against a
shark two sharks three sharks and I run
lady and when he said Clash the Titans I
was super sold so I gotta I gotta give
that to mark okay so it's 1:1 there
Spencer yeah III love the phrase
backdoor prequel and Mark I was really
on board with Meryl and then you seem to
bail at the end of in your rebuttal but
then you decided to fight again and
within the rebuttal I mean yet you had
me you lost me then you had me again I'm
calling mark with Meryl oh man
okay it is three two in favor of Mark
here is question number three of the
speed round Comedy Central will roast
Bruce Willis this summer what's the
worst all-time Bruce Willis movie cuts
him off what do you say Hudson Huck bad
movies a piece of sh hold on hold on
hey Spencer there's so many bad ones but
I'll do live free or die hard okay
Hudson Hawk versus live free or done or
die hard and we heard Hudson Hawk first
mark Hudson Hawk is a movie that was
made by like a jukebox that had nothing
but Sinatra in it high on cocaine there
is there is no sense of narrative Drive
there was no sense there's no sense of
fun in this movie that seems like it
should be all about Bruce was having fun
the fun that gets to be had is not by
Bruce Willis there's a crazy wacky stuff
with Richard II grant in there which is
which is kind of hilarious to watch I'll
watch the Sinatra cocaine jukebox and
like you said crazy wacky fun that is at
least interesting to me other than a man
phoning in his greatest role ever the
iconic role that made him known that we
all love him for to be just sleepwalking
through it like he had a gun to his head
off camera not on camera it was just
depressing and not only was it a bad
movie but it retroactively Lee ruins
other movies I mean listen I I will
watch the worst die hard movie and I
have quite a bit before I watch a movie
that feels like it was just nothing but
actor privilege I get to make a thing
that nobody can tell me I can't make I'd
rather watch it some guy's weird passion
project than a dispassion project he's
clearly wants to do like the life of
Bruno or whatever his band is with
Hudson hug he clearly doesn't want to be
John McClane anymore but we keep making
him or he keeps making us watch him wow
wow what a crap fest both of y'all bad
movie yeah we two dumpsters on fire
right next to each other but at the end
of the day we could only pick one of
these and man I thought Spencer really
sliced diced and julienned that argument
great rebuttal and yeah the dispassion
project i like that almost as much as
backdoor prequel my point to spencer
let's go to danielle i I gotta say it
Hudson Hawk and I
team hug Hudson Hawk it is a bad bad bad
bad movie jukebox with Sinatra on
cocaine almost sells it more than this
yeah well you picked a really cool way
to describe actor no narrative no drive
no fun I do agree but the idea that live
free or die hard which is the argument
that Spencer made ruined the other
movies in this series was depressing and
it was someone phoning in his greatest
movie ever
this passion project I gotta give it to
Spencer alright we are okay it comes
down to this question y'all all right
this is for everything ever everything
lost in all of ever passed out okay
which role would be more difficult to
recast Indiana Jones or Beetlejuice it's
a coin flip for me be a gentleman you
can pick is I could go either way it's a
trap
[Laughter]
I am gonna pick Indiana Jones I think
okay
Indy and Spencer you have beetlejuice
spy default Marc use but you chose first
and 20 seconds begin whatever you speak
I think that that Enid Jones as much as
I as as I love the character and hate
some of the movies that he's been in
namely that last one um I think so much
of that character is what Harrison Ford
is and what he brings to it that that
sense of kind of lackadaisical heroism
that sense have I been there before I've
seen this before I know how to deal with
it kind of I'm making it up as I go I
think that that's a really hard thing to
find these days I think these are both
archetypical characters Indiana Jones is
the swashbuckling gung-ho adventure and
Beetlejuice is like the disgusting gross
like 80s Andrew Dice Clay comic you can
recast a swashbuckling adventure you can
get another handsome guy in a hat but
you don't even want to see a Beetlejuice
character anymore you don't want to see
someone just like harassing women and
telling dirty jokes and looking nasty
like it's a type that doesn't sell
anymore I mean I think beetlejuice what
you're talking about is the fact that
the movie itself is kind of out of sense
with our modern sensibility but I think
that there are plenty of comic actors
that you could slather in makeup you
could make that a lot of fun there are
not a bunch of marquee level action
heroes like that anymore I think that
that role is much more synonymous with
Michael Keaton such that they've never
even tried to make a sequel never tried
to recast it whereas Indiana Jones
Spielberg's already talked about Indiana
Jane or whatever and he's already tried
with mud like he's clearly open to the
idea I'm wow how about it
okay let's go to Dan this is a fairly
easy for Marc for me I think that he
knocked down both why Beetlejuice would
be easier and why his role would be
harder so I am going to go with Marc in
this one yes I Spencer it seemed like
you had one argument and the first round
then you changed your argument for
Beetlejuice in the second round and your
ex your argument the first round wasn't
quite germane to the question it's like
we wouldn't want to see
a someone replace Michael Keaton so and
meanwhile I thought mark was a hammer
and nails in both of those rounds and
mark gets the point for me mark takes
the day Wow
[Applause]
yeah there's there's another point do
you know what March forget well fought
by everyone mark congratulations yes
please go ahead and plug some stuff and
tell us all about what's going on
Wow I mean I guess I'm honored and and
somewhat just chastened by the entire
experience I feel like I need a backdoor
prequel to what happened today I'm on
The Fatman on Batman podcast with Kevin
Smith we have a live show on Monday the
16th of April at the scum and villainy
Cantina so go on the interwebs and
finalists tickets and yeah man Castle
Rock a show that I wrote on last year is
coming out this summer so you should all
be scared by it I hope very cool awesome
mark thank you so much and congrats
well-fought good job thank you yell
Tebow so great to have ya break some
down for us what are you up to yeah I am
currently on the Africa's after show for
Legion every Wednesday night at 10:00
p.m. it's a mind mess also I will be in
universal fan kata in Baltimore at the
end of this month so please come and say
hello
awesome yo thank you so much for being
here
Spencer well played and funny stuff give
us anything you want to plug the Megan
theater he's got mega it's always super
fun sitting or standing you guys are
awesome took it to me and and please
awesome and let's go back to the Dan cam
oh the best Dan's in the biz Dan Morelle
yes and I want to say here's what I love
about the screen junkies audience you
throw down the gauntlet and they pick it
up we raised two hundred fifty dollars
during that speed
[Applause]
Thank You audience at home and please
continue to check out our women in film
event and donate and we'll be announcing
stretch goals as we rack up those
donations so thank you everyone at home
for this amazing two plus days that
we've had oh yeah
sweet you guys yeah don't forget to send
Danielle those corgis corgis all week
they don't just have to be today yes
send yell some porks and just you know
send me some merch I want to thank you
for watching you guys are awesome how
great is that that Dan mentioned it and
you guys rose to the occasion thank you
so much for being here and being a part
of all the good times I want to thank
Billy beers I wanna thank jte and
everybody who put this dog and pony show
together thanks for watching movie fight
time how rudnick hit me up on twitter
and instagram bye bye
you